evaluate zero plus y plus negative seven
when y is equal to negative three y is
equal to zero and Y is equal to seven so
let's take the first situation where Y
is equal to negative three then this
expression right here would be zero plus
negative three because that's our Y now
plus negative 3 plus negative seven plus
negative seven now zero plus or minus
anything won't change its value so you
can really just ignore the zero here so
this is going to be the same thing this
is going to be the exact same thing as
negative three negative three plus
negative seven plus it's a different
color plus negative seven negative three
plus negative seven and now we can draw
a number line here just to help us
visualize it but even if you didn't have
the number line you'd say look we're
already three below zero we're going to
go another seven to the left we're going
to go another seven more negative so
we're four three away from zero we're
going to go seven more away from zero so
we're going to be ten to the left of
zero or a negative ten or another way to
think about let me draw the number line
they're always better to have a visual
so we're starting so this is zero we're
starting at negative three we're
starting at negative three and to that
we're adding negative seven so we're
starting at negative three the absolute
value is negative three at our starting
point to that we're adding another
negative seven we're going to move
negative seven to the left so we're
adding let me draw this we're adding a
negative seven right over here we're
adding a negative seven right over here
so what's the length of this right over
here the absolute value of negative
seven is equal to 7 that's the length of
this error but we're moving it to the
left the length of this arrow right here
the absolute value absolute value of
negative three is three so we're already
three to the left now we're moving seven
more to the left so now we're going to
be ten to the left we are going to be 10
10 to the left 10 to the left this is
literally this is equal to
the absolute value of negative seven
this is let me do it in the order that
we wrote in the problem so this is equal
to the absolute value of negative three
you want to use the same colors the
absolute value of negative three plus
the absolute value of negative seven
plus the absolute value of negative
seven negative seven
but we're to the left we're to the left
of zero we've been moving to the left so
it's the negative of that which is
negative ten so if your signs are the
same you can just kind of you take the
absolute values of them say okay that's
how far we're going to move total and
we're that far away from zero to the
left since everything was a negative
number so the answer here is negative
ten so that was y is equal to negative
three let's think about when Y is equal
to zero when y is equal to zero this
expression up here becomes zero plus
zero our Y here is going to be zero let
me do that in that same blue color plus
zero plus negative seven plus negative
seven now you add zero to anything it's
not going to change the value so this
thing right over here this is pretty
straightforward these don't matter it's
just going to be equal to a negative
seven now let's do the last one when y
is equal to seven so our expression is
going to be zero plus our Y is equal to
seven so zero plus seven and then we
have a plus a negative 7 plus a negative
seven now there's a couple of ways to do
this you could literally just say well
adding a negative number is equivalent
to subtracting the number you could say
this is equivalent to 0 plus seven minus
seven plus negative seven is the same
thing as subtracting a seven the zero
doesn't matter so this is equal to 7
minus 7 which is equal to zero another
way to think about it let's draw a
number line let's draw a number line so
let's say that this is zero we're
starting off at seven so we're starting
off at seven where seven we are seven to
the right of zero and
to that we are adding a negative seven
so to that we're going to add a negative
seven so we're going to move two seven
to the left of where we were seven to
the left of 7 which is 7 to the right of
zero so this gets us back to zero over
here so the answer is zero